I wanted wrapping up the part two of the
[ __ ] 90 day fiancé
I did too I washed it last night I did
that was my big deal I didn't even watch
the whole season but you don't have to
you think how to jump in yeah you know
what the stories the obsession with
people's shitty marriages like the whole
[ __ ] network TLC is just people's
failing marriages it's great
what's the family Chantelle they show
90 day fiancé it's the we talking to
watch that dude I started tweeting about
it it's so did you see part one of the
reunion oh wait oh I know you're some
construction yeah there it is I hear
that's slight buzzing that's not Jim
humming no not at all no that's a
construction going on beneath us
yesterday so of course ninety-eight
fiancee is the show that we talk about
all the time by the way Jim and myself
obsessed with this show from season one
far longer than you know the world's
been obsessed with it I remember when I
saw a commercial for this show it was on
like when you get to the movies early
and they go like Oh coming to TLC this
fall is before the show even debuted I
watched the first episode of 90 day
fiancé
on television and I've been obsessed
with the show ever since it's the show
where they you know the person meets
their other potential spouse overseas
right and they bring them to the States
on a k1 visa and just about all the
marriages and in some form of disaster
well that's the ones they're showing you
yeah I'm sure that there's some that
they don't show and after a while I
think we get it the marriages suck
there's no mystery to it anymore that's
why I like it but not as much as I used
to because it was fun when some of them
wouldn't work in some of them would now
almost all of them are a disaster and
say okay I get it this is just one
disaster and some of it feels staged at
this point some of it doesn't but some
of it feels like oh okay
we know it like they know it sells they
know what sells they're gonna
selectively edit when I found out that
that shitty couple um Chantal and her
husband and whatever got the show even
though it's probably fun
watch them [ __ ] Hey it's like so they
it all feels fake they found the couple
that they had to probably fought the
most and the families hated each other
and the family so there are physical
fights it was Chantal and her husband
and her husband I think it's from
Dominican Republic right yeah not the
most reasonable right and they ended up
like the husband ended up getting into a
fight with her little brother and the
parents don't talk to each other and the
and the husband's sister called the wife
a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and all this stuff
has gone on they just constantly fight
that Chantal and her husband are
fighting over the families and they just
fight all the time and they announced at
the reunion that they're doing a
spin-off show where it's just gonna be
Chantal and her husband and they're just
following them around hoping that the
fights continue it makes me really
[ __ ] hate the producers why and you
know because you can just see that when
the couple is falling apart and I know
I'm a viewer so I know why they're doing
it I'm not part of the problem but when
I when you think about it and how like
these families hate each other and the
marriages are failing how the Glee it
gives the producers and I know it's a
business and these people have
volunteered I'm not saying anybody's
committing a criminal act it's just on
some level it makes me [ __ ] hate the
people to network but I think that this
has a lot more to do one it's one thing
if they start a certain way and it falls
apart and you document the falling apart
and make it look even worse it's another
thing when things fall apart and then
TLC goes do you want us to keep the
cameras around and we'll give you your
own series and they go that sounds like
a great idea like at this point it's on
the people I think it's in the way it's
always on the people I mean they make
the decision you know they're not used
to being on TV they know how they're
used to being on TV now there are yeah
but I'm saying when they first start
they take a they take responsibility
they sign up for it
but and then look we want interesting TV
but it makes me hate the network because
they never show the couples that are
doing well key that's not interesting so
and I know it's reality TV they set up
situations like the way they revealed
that Colt that Larissa had this little
boyfriend with her as a surprise the way
they revealed it the way they surprised
it's like they don't care that this
guy's pain is real like it is really I
get it I watched it you know I mean but
it's the teases you know the boyfriend
it just kind of I don't know make myself
a little bit for watching it - yeah
you're too sensitive about it
I mean all these it's not sensitive it's
it's it's hating them cuz I know that
these type of little [ __ ] weasels
behind the scenes are great oh we're
gonna reveal the boyfriend and I'm a bad
and to them it's just you ever see a
network when he [ __ ] says to Diana
it's all you know it's all seconds and
it's all broken down into seconds like
bottles of beer human stuff and that's
what it is it's like we don't give a
[ __ ] about the people not taking
advantage of the people like somebody
the same they are just makes me hate
think you didn't feel bad for cold I
felt bad for him yesterday yeah that was
pretty evil dude they're all kinda
everybody on the show is just trying to
get themselves over - sure like they all
if you do any research into all them
they all have little like side
businesses and they're all trying to
capitalize off everything nobody leaves
feeling victimized unless they disappear
from the show if you can hear that sorry
yeah I think so something on my mic is
not for me this is exactly why you
wanted to be able to switch out the
windscreen right you bet yeah I mean I
think that they're all like they're all
making that assessment like this isn't
one of those where people don't know
what they're getting into
and they're being taken advantage of
this is one where people know exactly
what they're getting into they know
exactly what they're doing 1% and they
want it they don't mind going through
this rollercoaster if it means they're
getting paid yep and again it's it's not
like I think they're being victimized
it's just when I look at it and I know
what it is it's like but again I watched
it I enjoyed it but it's just on some
level it makes me hate the people behind
the scenes can either scrambling around
their headsets alright who she's walking
I should walk it out get her walking out
get her walking out like you just know
the mentality of them we'll just want to
get good TV and they don't give a [ __ ]
about anything that's actually happening
and if something nice happens
don't want to show that because that's
not good TV and again [ __ ] us the
viewers me included because we don't
like the nice any more than do to say
I'm saying like you know to watch the
shitty - before I watch the good it's
kind of what we did on the radio for a
long time dude I mean again it's not I'm
not saying that these poor people the
networks were terrible I just when I
watched the whole overall thing because
they're not showing couples really doing
well much anymore I got it clear they
got Russ and Pao they do yeah but they I
think they brought them back here they
have a baby and they're one of a couple
the night of the baby I'll tell you what
it brought Russ and PAL back Russ and
PAL are the couple that we've been
following since season one they Ruggles
they brought Russ and PAL back because
Pao speaks up on every is so ready to
just explain what everybody is doing
wrong that they love that like has it's
so annoying to have somebody else who's
just in the same boat as you going like
no this is wrong you shouldn't be doing
this
you shouldn't be doing that you
shouldn't be doing this how many people
on that couch on that show we're like
shut up pal and why don't we land again
I'm guilty of it too so obviously we why
do we like the mess more like why is it
more fun to watch the disaster conflict
is interesting I guess oh yeah I mean
who cares about like if you're just
doing wow you're just doing well hmm you
know I mean I guess but there are shows
where people just are in love and do
well but they last like a season yeah I
don't I mean and then the fighting feels
fake on me like if they know they're all
being filmed they're doing a show I hate
when they have the measly meaningful
conversations in front of just don't
feel like I can trust you yes but you
weren't how come you're not bringing me
what I need because I had to go to work
plus you know you amp it up to two hours
got a lot of TV to fill but this is what
I mean like you you watch that one
episode that we watched a while back
where it was 90 days before the 90 days
and it was that guy who went to Columbia
and got stood up by the girl and he was
waiting there for like hours and the
girl was obviously just like you know
putting him through the ringer
and you could feel bad for him but at
the same time he was doing the same
thing to another girl yeah who was there
that he was just trying okay I get her
on the show and I marry her instead of
this one anyway I'm not believing her
and going back to his ex right so it's
like that was interesting because that
had an ending that was like yeah he went
back to the I took me that at least felt
like it worked out in a real way like it
wasn't just conflict like he meant the
one girl and it kind of long and it yeah
there's gonna be problems they're gonna
have to highlight that with the music
you know but he said to me he brought
two roses yeah I know I'm part of the
problem so I should just shut up I don't
know why I felt bad for that [ __ ]
cult yesterday why I just did he knows
what he's doing I know he does this I
still felt bad for him plus like every
story you read about mother Paul D
you're supposed to she's not very nice
to me so the show started with the
blonde and her Jamaican husband who's
like 23 yeah hey
the minute that he got to the states I
think they were married for like a
couple days and she caught him already
on tinder just trying to swipe me like
I'm an American now and it's just it's
just this little moment that I just like
started cracking up because they talked
to him and they go Jay how many women
have you slept with since being in the
United States and he goes to and they go
including your wife he goes yeah James
James kind of like he's very [ __ ]
shady but I think she's also difficult
yeah it's harder to when you're a young
guy and you're coming over and the woman
is a few years older and she has a
couple of kids it is it different but
she said at one point they were arguing
and he had like a whole other
relationship going on and was texting
and talking and and he goes well let me
just go and be happy she's my age and
that must have hurt oh he's always a big
thing for women because this little
blonde thing that married Jay like she's
very cute she's super cute she's not an
old lady
yeah but he's like 21 exactly yeah so
I'm swinging dick from Jimmy he's a
good-looking guy he shaves the little
cuts into his eyebrow
probably rolling in [ __ ] well yeah and
when we met them it was very clear that
the strong bond between them was mainly
sexual yeah it appeared that they liked
having sex all the time and even like
when they were gonna get married
every word out of this Jamaican kid J's
mouth was about [ __ ] her but he was
dumb though cuz he didn't wait like he
rushes it's like give yourself a time to
get used to the [ __ ] states and then
start [ __ ] around
look you're 21 21
you hear me 10 seconds ago and now what
I'm doing I'm right in again it's
interesting right back in I know I know
it's interesting we don't like because
you want to be better than this but
we're not God that's exactly all right
Travis said exactly it I want to be
better than this and I'm not none of us
are you're right I want to be better
than this and I'm not yeah I don't care
about it I'm not even trying to convince
myself that I should be but Travis hit
that's exactly what it was it's like I
really do want to be better not for
appearances but in my soul I want to be
better and I'm not but this is it you're
not better you don't have to be better
than this but I'm worse you can't be
worse it's okay better than this look if
you if you have people in your life
friends or whatever do that's that
wasn't the end of this if you have
friends in your life loved ones that are
going through relationship trauma and
you're like laughing at them and
entertained by that then you're a bad
person if you have people who volunteer
for a show put all their fights on
display knowing this is a show about
people fighting with each other knowing
yeah everybody knows what they're doing
here yeah and you watch that in you're
entertained by people entertaining you
with their nonsense it doesn't make you
a bad person
I don't feel bad when they if it just
doesn't work out like it happens like he
actually at one point said that he
didn't have sex with anybody and she
said really and he said
i but I realize like at times like the
pain these people have is real like so
you do kind of at times feel bad for
them even though they're on TV and they
volunteer for it's like you know like
that they are being kind of you know
devastated by some of these things I am
curious though as to what happened to
some of the other couples I mean think
about it your Jamaican kid 21 22 23
Irish guy yeah I understand how your
there he said like it's he they said he
was just [ __ ] everything that moves
in Jamaica when he was living there yeah
you give to the states they probably
like white women I would imagine he went
to the states with one right you get
into the United States
you see these apps where there's just
hundreds and hundreds of women at your
disposal the type of women you used to
[ __ ] Jamaica as tourists right now
they're everywhere and they got money
and they got money and you think at his
age you can be strong enough to sit
there and go you know what before I do
anything like this I should wait he's a
good-looking guy too
yeah yeah like that's a I mean it's like
being a little kid going into a candy
store and saying I shouldn't have any
dessert until after dinner yeah you know
I mean you can't you how could how could
he wait but it was so funny when the
other guy looked at James like you
[ __ ] dark bag scumbag playing that
who's the other guy big got the big guy
with the [ __ ] beard [ __ ] Russian
guy with the bowtie or she's right guys
a problem he probably a giant your boss
he shits yeah yeah punch through a wall
yeah you know treating her right yeah
he's a big dude so you know I I think
most of my attention was focused on
Larissa and Colt this is the couple that
we've talked about culty he is the
Godzilla shaped young man he yes exactly
the new Godzilla [ __ ] yes he perhaps has
he's perhaps on the spectrum judging by
the way he sits now I've heard is that
feet pointed out in his hands on his
legs he crazy the worst Center ever
people say that he's not that nice of a
guy and he's very into like strip clubs
and and fine and chicks they're going
apparently he's kind of perverted
apparently not like in an unhealthy way
but apparently he's kind of perverted
and they just don't show that part of
him on the show it's not true he's a
good boy he lives with his mom let's go
have some beef stew that sounds like
that Debbie no unfortunately Larissa and
Debbie never really got along they were
at odds yeah there was a lot of conflict
on the show at one point culty did call
the police on Larissa and filed charges
for physical assault all times multiple
times charges were dropped
yeah but there were multiple charges of
physical assault yeah there was another
you know regrettable moment when Larissa
took off her wedding ring an engagement
ring as well the diamond ring and
flushed it down the toilet and they
discussed how much it was worth last
night there was a they were didn't agree
on it they did not agree sighs I'm
wondering he is I'm a lot of money and
they said how much was did you spend for
that and he said he spent $2,000 and she
took issue with that and said he didn't
spend more than 200 on that ring so
she's thinking 200 and the mothers
chimed and the mothers got she just sits
there with her and I paycheck in
flushing it down the toilet I just loved
it the mother she's in on it but yeah
that's also where you know what's going
on that the mother sees the financial
value of the ring not like you know I
feel like it's one thing if it's two
thousand dollars or two hundred or
however much it was but really the
symbolism of taking your engagement and
wedding ring whatever it is and flushing
it down the toilet that should hurt more
than the financial value three people
walked off lesson that's my favorite
things there's always someone who storms
off set right but then they come back
after the break or see they come right
back because they love the cameras they
could leave at any time
we're just not going to begin with of
course you don't have to go you realize
oh this show is really a toxic thing I'm
not gonna go back that's why I don't get
upset about it because they already know
the toxic environment that they're in
they're volunteering for the toxicity
and they go can I please have some more
I bet you Michael from [ __ ] where is
he from was he African or from is
Michael the one that supplied the guy
who was like oh she's she's fat
yeah she's from Africa and he had an
overweight blonde white woman meet him
in Africa and he looked for clothes that
were flattering for her and he let the
store clerk know she's a little
embarrassed to try things on because
she's fat yeah she is fact I'll bet you
he is still trying to parlay that into a
season two and trying to find another
girl it's me I have another that someone
I guarantee all these guys that are no
longer on of course are looking even
though he doesn't understand he wasn't
the he was interesting because he was
dating her exactly but they all want a
little more of that rub they all want
more Fame um I don't know we got a few
cliffs how did the Russian kid doing
with his good well yes he like that's
one of those that I think that that is
okay yeah that's where they kind of make
up a little of the tension like I think
he's just got normal issues where the
dad and the son-in-law don't get along
that well no no no not them I mean the
one who had the baby in Russia but he
didn't file her papers oh it seemed like
they were doing okay
I think they were doing okay that's why
they don't spend much time covering yeah
and that's kind of annoying I'd like to
see them doing well and and the British
couple the the guy who was here now yeah
she's over there they're doing fine but
isn't it like are they married yet
they're married yeah and he can't get
over here he can't cuz he's got assault
charges no will he ever get that dropped
er no I will you ever be able to or no
they don't know I'm not a Bobby yeah
that's true when you are in someone's
lap because I'm bobbing you want to see
a clip of Larissa and Colt just kind of
talking about their marriage to bring
everybody up to smoke a let's go to
track one it was a great show I mean I I
missed several episodes this season me
too but I felt okay cuz it yeah you
don't need to watch every episode no
it's just more fights my favorite one is
the [ __ ] I also love the [ __ ] the
chubby white girl who's dating the guy
from Morocco and at the end of it they
realize she's like yeah people are
asking why we're not married cuz it's
been three and a half years obviously
what the [ __ ] yeah
three and a half years
hasn't seen her in a year they haven't
seen each other in a year yeah I mean
that's that's I don't think that has a
great future absence can make the heart
grow fonder though yes and apparently
that doesn't make the waist grow thinner
okay she wouldn't like to hear that well
I mean look that's probably the problem
why he's probably not doing it because
she's a big girl
she did when he met her he didn't
mention he was disappointed with her
size did he really not do it and it's
been 3 and 1/2 years and you're not
dropping it and she hasn't dropped wait
no no no and Russ and power just sitting
in the middle so pal can sit there and
judge everybody she's the greatest so
you're using Debbie as an excuse no yes
you just said you wish I was the man for
you your husband for you but Debbie like
you could have been a wife anytime you
could have been there for me I don't
think you've done anything for me at all
in the time of it we remember when it's
right you clean the house like a cat you
know industry knows a lot and we won't
call all the woman there you don't like
this I think when they show the faces
like they're all looking [ __ ] either
they just take shots of them looking and
dub it in to get reaction laughing at
him like I think it's so funny to watch
a couple arguing on television it's one
of the biggest shows on cable and
they're just sitting there going
remember I tried to clean the house and
Debbie was like oh you can't clean the
house we got into a fight and it's like
that's what we're watching yeah it's
great if it's just watching people it
does make you feel better about your own
interactions you're like oh I'm doing
great I'm so my relationship is so
healthy by the way Brian and filly is
exactly correct yeah I know I'm gonna
keep watching for all the [ __ ] [ __ ] I
just talked I'm not better than this
Travis am I better than this all where's
Travis you went to Rupp rather than this
- I don't know why you were you were
going off on that well I do something
I've wanted so woke all of a sudden no
wasn't why just was annoyed with myself
I'm like why am i enjoying this but
that's Travis at the Nelnet you became a
woke sjw hello white male
sis white male what's up Brian hey guys
good yeah machine we're sexy Chantelle
is yelling at kulfi and she says don't
say another word to me and Colby just
sits back and he goes two things three I
don't know thank you buddy I mean the
fights between the couples interacting
with each other is great and that's
another reason by the way why Chantelle
is the one that got the spin-off show
just because she's a super hot I don't
yeah I guess she is she's a little ditzy
like the more you get to know her the
more like this is a lot to deal with
she's a bit of a ditz a little she's a
bit of a ditz do you find her to be dis
Rob oh yeah
did you watch her show at all I haven't
seen it yet no there's so many hours of
this I only have so many hours hey I'm
trying to raise my own family you know
that before the 90 days starting of
course they all right this is becoming
the 90 day Network you guys watching you
watching the other way not yet I'm sure
it's amazing you like these shows I'm
addicted they're great I like two shows
on television this one in ancient aliens
no what is it what is the and then what
is the 90 day the other way yeah it's
when they go they go their route I mean
it sounds amazing it sounds [ __ ]
incredible this old lady goes with this
young Indian guy moves over to India he
wants her to wear like the traditional
stuff of course they're in India he
never told her his parents so he lied to
his parents to move somewhere else and
then the old lady's upset how old are we
talk him she's probably in her 60s he's
probably thirty that's great see already
I'm hooked I think that sounds amazing
yeah it does sound interesting people
moved to third world countries and it's
awesome so funny the guy the couple that
with it with the chubby lady there and
her and her husband and or boyfriend and
Morocco Nicole and Azen thank you yes
are you gonna move there with him and
it's almost like do you really think he
wants to live in his home country with
her he wants to get to America I gotta
live there with her of course yeah you
got shot goose you're gonna have Chantal
on this new show running around in a
bikini on the Dominican Republic and
then fighting with
in law that sounds like a great show I
just don't like when it feels forced and
feel like I like it was gonna be
conflict and they show it okay fine
bro but I don't it's like you know that
that a lot of them are just like oh
here's the two families what are you
watching
yeah I mean this is what this is yes it
is something else kind of funny I don't
if you noticed like when they take a
break and stuff they're all drinking Red
Bull of course they are like that makes
perfect sense that's just trying to Jack
them up of course that's your way
caffeined up right you're another red
bill they're trying to give them
six-packs of Pepsi of course there's
liquor of course there is go drink yeah
yeah like cult let's relax have a shot
and you'll see we'll play a couple clips
the more cult gets worked up the more
he's like demanding that they do things
like he's trying to direct the show and
they never listen to him no they did
with one thing though well he was gonna
leave yeah it took him a while though
yeah all right let's go back to the
description it's cult and Larissa
talking about their marriage so you
could have been more patient
Marisa there were a lot of people who
questioned whether you even loved cold
what would you say to them I truly love
the quality in my way I did everything
for him you know
we had problems do you think Larissa
really loved you no I don't know what of
course not no course not she might have
on some level had something for him but
you're such a sucker for love no I just
she wanted to come to the stage she a
hundred percent but I also think that he
was in the mother thing like I think
that might have just been her what the
[ __ ] is this it was the torso thing -
yeah the torso things knock Larissa is
hot
a bit naughty but hot it I think she's
my opinion that she has some kind of a
personality disorder yeah but hot yeah
yeah not hot
what's that probably a lot of fun oh yes
but not hot enough she has kids she said
that at the end I want for my kids I
didn't know she had kids with not in the
States but not hot enough to pull this
off like with call as difficult yourself
with call you have to figure out like
what is the what's the ratio here Colt
never got a woman like that before that
I guess rock his world like that's true
you think she [ __ ] him good amazing and
I'm gonna make a wild prediction here
I don't think Colt looks that good naked
I disagree I think he may have torso
issues maybe and this feet little feet
point out I think so I think so I mean
there's times where he has full-on
breasts look let's and we go refer to
them as torso issues let's keep it fair
you know yeah he had a lot of time to
slim down he didn't did he still have
the breasts at the Reunion oh yeah yeah
he did yeah it's very very busty busty
whose meat loaf in Fight Club you know
meat loves nickname and Fight Club was I
believe [ __ ] tits yeah okay okay just
making sure we're all on the same page
Larissa love me but the way she acted
she never listened to anything that I
needed or wanted from her she always
complained about my mother or money or
the car or everything was wrong with her
work out you ignored me 99% the time I
just said wanted a hug you called me
needy I asked you to calm down not to
yell and scream and go crazy cuz you
wanting to clean the garage I said just
chill out we can't not even get along
together as a couple and you're worried
about cleaning garage yes he wants a hug
feels you're needy needy hug go clean
the garage in needy yeah and then we'll
go straight to the third clip because
the mom came on pointed it's always good
when you're confronting your ex-wife on
television because they're divorced now
already Colton and Larissa yeah it's
always good when you're confronting your
ex-wife on television to have your mom
there to support you yep you know can
you already hear the Jim impression can
you hear this like it's a spot-on
impression and what's amazing is Jim
does a pretty good physical impression
of her as well thank you that was not
intentional oh you didn't come in your
in your Debbie outfit no I didn't okay
my mistake looks like an old male
country-western singer like Porter
Wagner towards the end yeah yeah should
be [ __ ] getting a Lifetime
Achievement at the Grand Ole Opry it's
got a rhinestone jacket on with with
fringes on the arms boy there's a lot of
cameras there yeah they got a lot of
cameras they want to make sure they
catch everything they film everyone yeah
they got tons of cameras so they get
every bit of footage that you can get
and lots of coverage backstage her
upcoming court date isn't very far away
I don't want her to be deported
because there's only sheets here she'll
always have quote to fall back on and I
don't want that nice she's getting
skinny I'm on watching yeah hi baby
Hey hi Debbie how are you fine how are
you I'm fantastic my question to you is
what was it like living with Larissa
during this time she talked about my
science man look as skinny cults ankles
are yeah I mean you wonder yeah how can
ankles that size support what's above it
my son has tiny and my toes in the
little head he has parentheses disease
so you say you just got the font size
all wrong the font size is 16 the
parentheses is a 7 bowling shoes they
see the head is depressing because when
somebody's got a head that size and
ankles that size you realized that
they're not the genetics haven't made
them overweight right you know what I
mean when you see a fat guy with a fat
head you go you know it's one of those
things where there's probably a lot of
genetics he's gonna have to work really
hard to get that weight off because he's
probably got a lot of fat folks in his
family when you see a guy with a small
head and small ankles in a big fat torso
you go okay that's just indulgence
that's just somebody who would enjoys a
treat
hell it was health is very moody one day
she wake up she's happy is gonna be
she's all friendly in the nest station
to wake up and she wouldn't talk to you
Larissa was that true were you very
moody with Debbie would she try to say
good morning I never blame you 100%
Debbie you to Lisa me I always say what
a good mother you'll take care of your
son but yes I won't lie to you I wanted
to leave with the Kotel on
and yes I agree with them it was very
multi and I was very bad for it I mean
to be fair to Larisa living with
somebody in their mom yeah I mean coming
to another country to marry a man and
then you have to live with his mom yeah
it's not exactly a dream scenario and
his mom is not like just in the bedroom
ill his mom is like running the
household right and if she got a very
annoying voice as she runs the house
where's my hair where's my hair gel you
threw your rig down the toilet patient I
know I am why does Colby's mom know
anything about Cole T's paycheck
shouldn't my mom doesn't know anything
about my paychecks I love my mother I
bet she does to call T just put your
buddy your my account I'll handle it
I'll make you some of the succotash in
the morning is breakfast yes nice
rolling paper you're gonna have a double
LP mother was a little bit of a [ __ ]
remember how upset she got when Larissa
wanted the slot machine that was in the
dining room Lois asked shitty though she
and Larissa said Larissa said that she
wanted the slot machine thrown out
because here's a slot machine in the
living room who's ready for it to go in
the garbage and yes and Debbie was
extremely pissed so this was very rude
Larissa wizard and she would walk around
in her underwear all the time I would
like that I would like that but my mom
would hate it it's your big fat ass
imagine live with your mom and Larissa
is walking around with her ass cheek
sticking out all the time like your mom
doesn't need to know what you're saying
what her sons tapping right yeah no
mother wants to know Butler isn't made
it known she did yes she did
Debbie did you want cult and Larissa's
marriage to succeed
I don't hate Larissa I hate what she's
saying but of course when involving your
son she'll take care of you she
protected me I tried to stay away from
them as much as possible to let them
live their life yeah it's hard though
when you're the [ __ ] in the same
kitchen trying trying to elbow each
other I had to use the same one frying
pan in the household yeah everybody
needs eggs
yeah the ownership pull the real [ __ ]
move yesterday she did you want to go to
clip four to me this made the show I
don't and that's why they did it I know
all my nonsense before I watched it that
was great yeah I guess my human drama
I know come on I guess I would want to
get back with Larissa everything over
okay right so here we are we're like
okay said he loves already he days like
I still love you and she said never say
never and you're like oh my god
maybe we're gonna see Colt and Larissa
get back together these another divorce
the divorce now but still some bonds are
just too strong to be broken right right
so you're not saying no no what are you
their whip somebody okay stop it hos and
she looks on top at home she looks up at
smiles at somebody off camera and they
and then yeah that this is where they
then exact again it's TV but no it's
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] dude it's
exposed later in the show that there's a
producer in the room with Larissa
even though Larissa is joining them on
skype there's a producer in the room and
this guy has to be miked the other guys
to be miked of course the other guy has
to be miked so everybody who's making
the show is aware all guests on the show
are invited guests yeah okay
[Music]
you're with your boyfriend Eric right is
he listening to this and they pull back
in he's sitting right there off-camera
while she's on the bed and he's already
made he's been miked yep ready to just
jump on ready to jump and they're
giggling cuz i by the way i bet he came
in recently he wasn't there the whole
time he came in probably yet he probably
listened on a monitor
our chair was waiting for him okay go go
go yeah so just in case you made any
sounds or anything yeah he friend just
heard you say you would basically think
about getting back together with no I I
don't say that I wanted let us say that
no so I don't know answer yeah well her
dumb smile she thinks it's funny
yes like how hilarious is this you were
just like maybe we'll get back together
and I was like this is the dude I'm
[ __ ] yeah yeah and cold is like I'm
like cold can't be happy
this guy's like he's in pretty good
shape good-looking guy he's in better
shape yes better shape yeah I thought it
was fairly hateable but yeah of course
he's made of mr. roley's plan he's a
scumbag but I don't know these are not
he's met a girl she was divorced he's
laughing at her ex on TV like haha I'm
[ __ ] this chick you brought her over
here but now I'm [ __ ] ya in that funny
that's not a nice thing to do that's
very mean probably he's a bad guy I met
her on tinder of course she did that's
kind of hitting the jackpot yeah cuz now
you got this TV she was on tinder
fretless she's doing the same thing this
Jamaican Jay was yeah does that mean
you're thinking about it are you legally
married still no we're not Larissa can
Eric pop in
see what a spontaneous what a
spontaneous call by the host how do you
think Eric could just pop in that chair
that you're sitting in like a rich pop
in yeah would you guys mind sitting on
the bed together by the way I love how
she's talking into an iPhone but they
have giant cameras they can put it like
I'm lighting yeah I'm lighting right
that's not an iPhone that we're seeing
by the way you're not watching her
through an iPhone I don't think is that
his iPhone have that good of connection
uh I think it is good if you could in
good internet yeah it could be yeah it
could be in the room cuz she is skyping
in but yeah I mean but there's other
full-fledged cameras in there with her
for other shots yeah koltes bombed-out
yeah Colton's bum now is the mayor of
bum City yeah
the body language was not good cuz when
he sat down he casually put his arm on
the bed but he put it over her entire
body almost like he was wrapping her
legs in his arm and it was like very
possessive like to say this is my chick
I'm a good-looking guy in good shape and
this is the girl that I'm with and culty
was like yeah we're just because right
before you got here we were just you
know maybe talking about getting back
together you know I got her into the
country just thinking maybe we talked
about that I didn't know you were coming
she probably thought he could have her
back whenever he wanted but this dude is
there now yes he is yeah that's thanks
I suppose me from the internet I'll tell
ya actually I got now a relationship and
that day
I messaged her we mash and when I met
her I was like wow wow
you consider Larissa your girlfriend
right I was saying wait is she not
considered there was a conversation it
is so weird like watching these two like
be cute together and it's like like they
have no idea
that's why Larissa is kind of hateable
right that everybody else is like oh my
god this is the most uncomfortable thing
I've ever seen and these two are just
like giggling like ah we're pretty girls
no Patrick Colt
shitty the mom is just sitting there
going like I don't know what to do
anymore
you have to deal with this yeah cult is
like do I just sit here with my mom now
yeah I mean he's his ex is with some
good-looking in shape guy and he's with
his mom
that's not a good look man oh I like
when she blurts out I want her to part
[Laughter]
it's a few seconds ago I asked Larissa
if she would want to get back together
with Colt and she said never say never
well if that's the case then I'll have
to hope for the best and prepare for the
worst
Larissa how would you describe this
relation I mean that you had he's so
condescending like he's sitting there
talking to the host going lady
I'm not worried she's not going back to
culty yeah and cause he's just sitting
there looking like hi what but but man
and that's why she didn't try go to New
York issues with her boyfriend guys
she's hanging out with her dude yeah
it's not nice no I believe there's
something legally involved where she
can't be there there might be yeah it
was her her third legal trial was coming
up oh no I know that yeah her third
third assault charges yes I see yeah you
think Larissa every now and then loses
her temper yep yeah
up with Eric do you consider him your
boyfriend I guess dad my boyfriend he's
very sweet he's hard-working he hits a
good partner when we argue we make it up
like this we always try to yeah they're
looking at cult just staring at the
ceiling like why God why is my life
ended up this way she says things like
he's hard-working and she looks at the
camera like unlike you cult
yeah it's we lit up I mean he puts up
with her [ __ ] yeah
calls just staring at the ceiling like I
don't know I wish one of these lights
he's staring ready to light going please
fall down on my head and kill me right
now because this is so humiliating
humiliating for you I went through all
the that's like what you do with your
significant other him it's mom is next
to his mom's yelling in his ex my son is
almost obese conditioned mom you're not
healthy mom please stop
Jenni more functional stop it mom help
at all
my son is gonna be crying all over his
own bosoms please please mom don't bring
up the bosoms again mom please please
don't bring up the bosoms my sons when
they see pointed out and his hands on
his knees what mom that doesn't where
does that have the argument mom it's not
in the budget right now it's not it's
not it's not in the budget or do you
think that that was what cult said to
her when she said you didn't bring me
flowers and he was like we don't have
the budget for it we have to we have to
be smart we have to make smart choices
on the budget do you think that she ever
hears it's not in the budget from this
stud nope nope you know I mind spending
a couple bucks
you're an ass larysa I poured my heart
out to you and you're laughing making
fun I used to respect you up until about
five minutes ago you lost your respect
mocking them because they're smiling as
they're arguing they really are they
have dumps we're gonna [ __ ] right after
this smile oh you think that's what that
smile is yep oh no do you think culty
and the mom know that they're doing that
that's a [ __ ] smile yep
oh no he goes like this
hey larysa you just lost her respect
like yeah he's a hateable they couldn't
care less they're talking to poor Colton
Colts mom like they're not even human
beings like they're just children
well let's go to Amy's real quick I
don't understand this anger what's up
Amy Amy in New York hey how are you guys
good Amy
I cannot stand POW home with a double
chin and not me she just had a kid
I don't care she's a nut job and I feel
bad for us well we like Thank You Amy we
like pal but she does her role and
that's why we don't really have that
many clips of Powys because her and russ
don't really fight so much pow just gets
involved in the other fights and tells
people what they should or shouldn't be
doing huh
and I think that's great how did the
when I met her in Dallas yeah I was
doing the Improv she did the was the
water by the ice bucket challenge oh my
god I remember that video yeah what a
video yeah she was really nice she's she
seems nice she's a delight she'll be
better on the show before many times we
when we first started we had times that
many would we had her on the phone but
we had rust and POW in studio when we
first first first started doing them all
right let's get back to called poor call
T and his mom not being taken seriously
at all
no so Eric do you feel threatened by
Colt at all absolutely
oh no the white you have to send to say
that do you I'm just kidding he's like
absolutely just like one is I got come
on larysa guerilla Larissa looks at
amigos you're threatened and he goes no
I'm not threatened what I'm him
no yeah Eric is Hannibal ladies looking
at that he's every highschool bully that
you ever had to deal with is this Eric
character but is one impression to make
though that's true on this show so he's
like I'm going for it yeah he did he's
actually playing his role very well he's
probably trying to get that spin-off
[ __ ] on everybody we're always trade by
them as she's sitting with her boyfriend
she said it's too toxic for her the
other people are too toxic for her she
hung up
[Music]
is he bothered no no what are you doing
he's done a lot of flies a lot of things
I don't want to be this anymore
well no when they come back with respect
Scully a lot of the things so she turned
off the phone but this is another thing
like she turned off the phone to be
dramatic and then she calls back she
turns it right back on and then cult
leaves and then he walks back on he
starts saying get them off the screen
and they're like what no no we're not
going to you think hey you get off the
screen and they're like no no called how
but the answers and the answer's no I
don't know what else you want to cover
here I guess we could just kind of cover
the end I mean we don't hope sex is my
favorite oh I was thinking clip six okay
clip six is uh is this is when so now
Larissa is called back colt has walked
off Colt has also come back but he comes
back now and he's saying I want Erik off
the screen and Erik is the new boyfriend
who's like I think I'm gonna stay and
that's where we're at
Erik I don't care but I want you off
your do what you want the screen the
fact it didn't work you're not a part of
this do you see larysa laughing yeah I
haven't cuz he goes he goes and she goes
laughing she's laughing she's got her
mouth covered he goes I want you off the
screen why you don't always get what you
want oh [ __ ] oh yo your I don't care but
I want you off
you're distresses that date you want
what you want you can't always get sir
great it didn't work you're not a part
of this dude off looks like I am oh he
just he just has these hateable
hateable eyes expressions yeah he goes
look like I it looks like I am and he
looks around the room and all the lights
and stuff and then he looks directly
into the camera lens as if he's piercing
the soul of cult himself like what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do about it and
leaning on his shoulder Larissa's
leaning on him like oh my signing white
knight watch your cold stance I've just
go back to history I don't want that
watch how his feet point out he's argent
ODE he need no no no pigeon-toed
he needs arch support he'd that way he
points out because there's a lots of
balance on the sides we don't want that
being pointed out they go to the sides
[Music]
call pratas mom is our dummy if that was
a good idea I miss mother I hear madam
Colton pretty girl where would he bring
you yeah first mom what are you doing
here and I just love cuz he goes like he
goes like he's telling all the producers
he leaves the state soundstage and he's
telling all the producers get him up off
the stage or get him off the screen and
they're all just kind of looking at him
like that I don't think we can do that I
think I'm probably just gonna probably
leave him there for the time being it's
too good right Oh Goldie her dumb smile
his mom is just sitting there on the
couch Nicole thought he was actually
gonna probably it back with her it with
this this is like a reunion yeah I
more wine just Allah doesn't matter the
producer just goes up to him and goes
are you ok call goes no poor cult is
right she does have her court case
though they die like that they kind of
hung in there and finished it up with
her court case yeah you want to see the
court case yeah it's almost I mean just
the very end ok go to clip 9 to wrap
this up she goes into court and are
there I [ __ ] in the courthouses their
people drilling and hammering yes so are
the judges I could hear yeah yeah yeah
this is from the show and she has the
assault charge the third one she still
with the guy Eric and I looked up
because I was like is this guy fake is
this put on and I looked up Larissa's
Instagram and he's been on her Instagram
for the last six months
oh it's may be together for a while yeah
they've been together I think since like
the beginning of the year based on the
Instagram I knew this was coming
oh yeah but did you know they were in
the same room no I didn't see that that
was a nice little surprise little how do
you do so she's not getting back with
cult no this guy's in much better shape
and appears to support her much better
too he seems like he's a little nuts
himself you have to be you have to be
it's in there you don't need to look you
know you don't need to do anything it's
going I don't know if you dare be ankle
chicken wings in my case it but I think
that both feet are dangerous and they
want three things hey guys
Araki she can't help it Araki yeah but I
wonder this is the lawyer Eric who's
slightly he looks exactly like the
boyfriend except slightly taller and
slightly better looking yeah so I wonder
if now the boyfriend who's such a
[ __ ] it's going up oh just in case
not they should have [ __ ] a lawyer why
I mean maybe but I mean the lawyers
protect [ __ ] to do maybe you're right
he's just negotiating her down a
misdemeanor you know needs a life ruined
no it's your marriage
I don't know so it's very important so
basically this counter is a fake
conversation oh it is yeah do you think
the person asked you if you go to jail
do you think I can go negotiation we
make today you go along with those
requirements
okay all this may have happened after
the case anyway you don't know when they
actually had the conversation Oh like
they film it after they leave the court
they they already know the results yeah
I don't like to see all we can just go
to them right there you know just the
very end all right let's see when Colt
shows us yeah Colt and his mom show up
I'd like to see here Colt commentary on
the whole thing Colt has grown his hair
out a little bit at slicked back he's
got a blue wait some yeah not all it's a
process good ass yeah that's that's the
issue yeah that really is one of the one
of the key issues here this whole thing
that ass has made a lot of men do a lot
of things you think hold my son yeah
he's probably had she took care of him
when she needed to he just she rocked
his world
yeah but she's probably had a lot of
partners that look like that no okay
alive important
call his mom pull up of course two of
them yeah well
Colts got a riding style I'm a little
cautious about seeing the rest of the
day I was really depressed after I came
back from the tell-all it was really
hard I felt like I hit rock bottom
hey pockets yeah I mean with the torso
issues that we discussed before you
don't want to put your hands in your
pockets cuz it opens up your jacket and
and the hands is kind of flop out like
they're half in the [ __ ] because the
slacks are tight because of the thigh
issue that we haven't discussed yet but
it's similar to the torso issue juicy
thighs does does a lot of meat on their
bones hmm I feel like she played me and
I don't really want to see her I think
she should be executed she gets away
with everything in her line so at this
point I would like her to take
responsibility for something I think she
probably will what larysa I think she'll
probably find I think so yeah I think
it's absolutely oh it's just cigarette
so she's got to stay they plead it down
to like I'm she has to do community
service and some nonsense but she gets
to say the moment on this reunion
special that really broke Colt was when
the boyfriend goes if need be I would
sell my house and move to Brazil with
her and Colt he goes whoa what's going
on what's going on cuz you realize how
real it is yeah um no you lost her yep
at the end she says culty and Debbie
socket because they don't control
whether or not she stays anymore nice
you know cold and Debbie suck it I got
two words for you
suck it and now you know she has to she
has to fight she has to us to try to
immigrate here
yeah but Eric ain't moving to Brazil and
she won't want him in Brazil ah she
wants to be here she wants to go she's
in Brazil she don't want some brazilian
guy yeah absolutely
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM a/v